[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report at presented by
fanduel it is the playoffs
so we're doing it big for you guys today
i'm greg ivory alongside the man
the myth
the legend sam richmond sam
how you feeling about these matchups
brother
well first you always give me the best
intro so that always starts the show off
with great vibes but man i am so excited
just some of these first round matchups
are unreal i mean net celtics feels like
could be in the eastern conference
finals i can't wait man i'm pumped
cannot wait a lot of good matchups
but we are here giving away locks we're
giving away hoodies we're giving away
jerseys
basketball shorts the ones that i do not
have and you know what it's the playoffs
and i'm feeling generous so i'm giving
away an iphone today as well so i need
you guys to get in the comments i need
everybody to get in the comments i need
gifts i need emojis but most importantly
i need winners only please in fact i'm
giving out some of those shorts right
now sam i'm in the comments i am in the
comments and i see scuba trouba he gave
me the gift the tyler the tyler uh
the tyler gift the tyler creator gif uh
it's giving me a a little a little grin
so i guess for the vibes for the vibes
i'll give him a hoodie shout out to you
you are walking away with the hoodie
we're hey we're big on vibes here
today we are bringing back the 3x2
parlay for cleveland atlanta and the
clippers pelicans boosted from plus 410
to plus 500 the question is will there
be two or two or more three-pointers in
the first three minutes of each of those
games get in the comments and tell us if
you are riding with us sam
talk to me
talk to the people you can see the odds
right here on the screen what are you
thinking
yeah i mean the plus 500 is super
intriguing we have uh well he he's uh
there's a guy on twitter excuse me named
three by two guy he crunches the numbers
and he has uh has this parlay at plus
360. so to get it at plus 500 is great
man i mean it's a parlay you never know
but there are worse dart throws to make
than uh than one at a plus 500 three by
two parlay
sam is sitting sending good vibes we'll
take the good vibes i'm in the comments
sam i'm in the comments because i got to
give away some of these hoodies uh here
we go
i see
polstra
postra19 says atlanta hawks moneyline
plus the under winners only please i
love that i i like that i like that
shout out to the shout out to you for
the winners only please shout out you
are walking away with the hoodie but sam
guess what
i mean
it would not be a show if we are not
riding the three by two parlay so we are
all riding the plus 500 three 3x2 parlay
as a family
so let's get rich but this is my
favorite part of the show show sam
because we get to talk major markets
money lines against the spreads and
point totals for tonight's game let's
take a look at the odds sam what are you
seeing here and what do you like
yeah i think my pick might be a little
bit controversial but i i know paul
george is out i'm still gonna take the
clippers tonight look i think ty lue one
of the best coaches in the nba um and
they've dealt with not having pg and
kwai all year
i think this is one of those spots where
you have a group of really good veterans
who step up in the absence of a star and
i think the clippers get it done at home
tonight
sam is rocking with the clippers i'm
taking a look at the early game the
hawks cleveland cavaliers a lot of
money's been coming in on those atlanta
hawks you see the cleveland cavaliers
are
the cleveland cavaliers actually are the
underdogs at home
i like this spot i like it a lot give me
the underdogs at home and let's take it
to the bank uh i'm in the comments
though sam because i want to see what
they are talking about see what vibes
they are leaning on uh br banning says
thanks for the vibe sam they're in the
comments shout out to you br betting uh
i got
jojo473454 if he said he liked the
clippers money line people are sleeping
on how well the clippers did with
injuries last year shout out to you uh
the comments are jumping now sugar shane
zero five one five pales minus four
hawks minus four let's rock i think
those are alternate spread parlay shout
out to you sugarchain i got one more
snoopy 20 2153 says it should be a slate
of good games i agree everybody that i
mentioned you all are walking away with
hoodies sam we talked major market now
let's talk player props it's time for
lock or not i'm gonna put up a prop and
i need all of you to get in the comments
and tell me whether it is a lock
or not sam let's get straight to it
which start off with ya boy trey young
ice traitor gang uh to score 30 points
tonight sam sitting at -106
do you think my guy trey young can get
it done
it's one of those that feels a little
too easy so i'm kind of scared off by it
but
i do like it i like it look i think trey
young has proven over a short career
that he
loves these moments uh he lives for
these big games he lives with the
spotlight to be on him he's also played
well against the cavs this year
averaging 32 and a half and they're four
games against them so i think he comes
out firing tonight now i think he does
get 30.
i like that too sam i i like trey young
here to get 30 points he had 24 in his
last one uh but it was a blowout you
know what i mean but
trey young has been in his back i just
want to say that trey young has been in
his back over the last month the end of
uh march early april he's been in his
back and and it's a baseball term but
i'll use it here in this spot when trae
young goes so does the hawk when he goes
they go so he knows what he's up against
he knows what he has to do
they need a big game from trae young 30
points i can easily see him going to go
get it let me
see what they are talking about in the
comments
i see rb139 says not i think he says
that he's not gonna get it he said they
play a lot of team ball multiple players
and double digit points okay rb 139
shout out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie thomas folks he gave us
one word sam he said a lot shout out to
you thomas you were also walking around
hoodie uh let's move on the clank
compeller sam clint capela 13 plus reboy
rebounds
sitting at minus 134
talk to me talk to the people do you
like this one
yeah it's a big number but i do look i
think
obviously one of the best rebounders in
the league and i think the fact that you
have no john collins for the hawks and
you have jarrett allen back for the cavs
that's the the hawks are going to have
to go with some bigger lineups you might
see clint capela more closer to 30
minutes sometimes he's playing around
20-25 but
if the cavs are going to go big the
hawks might have to go big and if he
plays around 30 minutes i think he does
get 13.
i can see i can see your opinion sam i
definitely see your opinion and you have
a very very valid point
but 13
13 is just
that's a lot for me in the playoff game
sitting at -134
like
that it just scares me it just scares me
you mentioned alan coming back they got
mobley over there they got kevin i mean
o.g kevin love can still grab a rebound
or two it's just i 13
it's a lot i know he averages close to
12.
i'm gonna ride with you sam i'm gonna
ride with you just for the vibes i'ma
look into the comments though and see
what they are talking about uh
goat garden says nah be healed four says
darius will go off today shout out to
you two you two are walking away with a
hoodie and speaking of darius
we're talking about him right now to
have eight plus assists sitting at minus
one thirty sam talk to me and talk to
the people i think he can go get eight
tonight
well i gotta say just beautiful
transition by you using the comment to
springboard us to this one that was that
was expertly done but uh i do like it
look i think
i'm just gonna steal your your turn from
earlier you know the cavs go as garland
does and i think he's gonna have the
ball in his hands a lot tonight again
you get a jared allen back the cavs are
pretty deep uh i think you know garland
is gonna be
getting his teammates involved eight
assists not that many i think he
averaged 10 and a half for the entire
month of march so i do like this one
again tonight
yeah i like this one especially because
my guy jared allen is coming back we can
see we're going we're going to see a lob
or two tonight i i can tell you that
we're going to see a lab or two pick and
roll my man darius garland to allen
tonight
uh
and
last game he had five but he had 34
points he was looking to score the ball
in that match up against the nets i
think he's more in the playmaker role
here at home against those hawks and i
could easily see him getting those eight
assists and i mean the odds makers think
so too it's minus 130.
let me get into these comments let me
get into these comments young gravy 56
says dairy is about to about to be poor
after all the dimes he's dropping
tonight easy
luck i love the vibes there i thought it
was going south but then he took it up
north with some good vibes so i like
that there shout out to you young gravy
56 you are walking away with the hoodie
sam it's time to build
this br betting custom same game parlay
which you yes you
can ride along with us on fanduel
tonight we are looking at the clippers
pelicans game and i need everybody to
get in the comments and tell me what
they think
which legs are locks which legs are not
sam richmond are you ready to get right
to it
let's do it man i'm excited
let's get right to it we're starting it
off with bi
brandon ingram
two score 20 plus points tonight sam
talk to me
talk to the people i think this one can
is
easy for bi do you think he can go get
20 tonight
yeah i'm with you this is this is one of
the legs of the parlay that should be
it should be close to a lock right i
mean bi is a bucket he can get 20 in his
sleep he's been playing really well
recently he played well in the last in
the last playing game uh i think he gets
this easily
my man sam is sending us good vibe for
bi let's move on to his teammate
cj mccullum to score 25 plus now
i like this one
he has experience he has the playoff
experience on that pelicans team
do you like this one though sam do you
think he can go get 25 points tonight
yeah i think i think you you're right
you're right on the head like you have
the veteran presence of a cj mccollum
who's been in these games before i
wouldn't be surprised if the young
pelicans team rode him uh pretty hard
tonight and he played really well in the
last playing game so and you know we
talked about earlier right
these are the games and these do or die
games you see the biggest stars go out
and let it fly and i think you're gonna
see that from cj i think you're gonna
see that from bi as well
cj bi now let's move over to the other
team
we're talking reggie jackson now sam i
say this almost every show you know how
i feel about three-pointers made and
betting on three-pointers made
multiple multiple three-pointers made
but
we're talking reggie jackson no kawhi
no paul george he's gonna have to be the
guy for this clippers team
i actually love this one talk to me do
you like this one or not
well i gotta say that is my favorite
part of every show and i agree with you
it's scary to rely on everyone else but
steph steph is like the lock but
everyone else is a little scary but i do
like it uh again
no pg it requires others to step up uh
reggie average i want to say two and a
half threes last month
in march so he's he's been getting that
number so i do like it tonight
sam likes it i love it let's move on to
the last leg
we mentioned no kawhi
no paul george reggie jackson is gonna
need some help
who else who better
marcus morris to help him out with 15
points tonight sam do you see this
happening
yeah i think this is like the x factor
of the parlay right you have like your
bi 20 points like that's gonna happen
this is the one that will decide whether
we hit or miss the parley i think but
again i think i think you're getting a
nice number here someone has got to step
up for the clippers they're under man a
veteran like marcus morris who is a big
game type of player 15 points isn't that
many i think he gets a couple threes i
think he does get it done
my man sam is sending us
good vibes for this parlay i really like
this part like a lot
let's pull up the tickets so i can put
this parlay in on my phone while i show
y'all how much money you guys can make
if you guys was to put a hundred dollars
down you'll be walking away with 378
dollars and eight
cents sam while i'm putting this parlay
in let's keep the graphic up there
because i want sam to grade the parlay
sam take it away what are you grading
this parlay
you betting the parlay live on air is
just absolutely immaculate vibe so i
love that but uh no i really like it i
think you and i have done a few of these
parlays i want to say this is near the
top of where i've you know felt best
about um
it's just it's a really nice parlay when
you have the two stars of the pelicans
and then you have two veterans on the
clippers who are gonna need to step up
without pg so in the in the spirit of
good vibes i'm gonna rock with an a
sam is rocking with a a
i love it sam i love the good vibes i'm
in the comments though i'm in the
comments because i'm giving away shorts
and a jersey k walker
heck if i would if callie would let us i
think he's talking about betting on
fanduel putting in the same game parlay
but he's in california hey i feel you're
paying uh
shout out to you you are walking away
with some br betting shorts i'm also
giving away a jersey sam i'm also giving
away a jersey boss band 2186 says solid
parlay give it a b plus i am finna ride
i love the vibes please ride you are
walking away with a jersey of your
choice
i'ma give away one more one one more one
more pair of shorts uh steve santa bria
says that parlay is money he gave us
fire emoji sam appreciate you i think
the parlay is money too and we are all
gonna catch the playoffs are here and
drake
put 200k on my golden state warriors to
win let's take a look at that massive
bed slip that he put sam
we're gonna get it up we're gonna get
this is me and sam looking but we're
gonna get that massive bed slip that
drake place there it is
that's the massive bed slip right there
my man is putting the coins down on the
warriors looking to get a milli back sam
i like it i love it you guys know how i
feel about my golden state warriors in
the west this isn't even the
championship sam we just gotta get
through the west
talk to me talk to the people what's
your take on it do you like drake's pick
or uh are you not so much feeling it
well i'll try and be quick here because
i really just want to hand it off to you
and let you go for three minutes and and
just talk about the warriors because
that is my favorite thing ever but i do
like it look i think five to one is a is
a really good number um and i i really
like the warriors path i've i've talked
on the show i was kind of sneaky looking
at the nuggets but that was uh dependent
on jamal murray coming back and it
doesn't seem like that's going to happen
so i do like the warriors in that first
round and then you get probably the
grizzlies in the second round and i
don't want to give any disrespect to the
grizzlies they are absolutely amazing
but it just kind of feels like
the warriors would win that series right
you have a veteran team a hungry team
who was championship or bust
all the time and then you have the
grizzlies who are going to be able to
say this was an amazing year regardless
of how it shakes out um so i think the
words would get past then and i think
obviously i think the suns or
i sneaky like the jazz to to make it
that far but i won't get into that uh
whoever makes in that series that is
going to be an absolute dog fight um but
i think the warriors are absolutely
loaded if steph is at full strength and
can win it so i i took longer than i
should huh you you talk about the
warriors man you let it fly no no no
brother you were hitting it right on the
nail in the first series against the
nuggets we all know the warriors
struggle against big man and they have
jokic but i can see the warriors uh
shooting threes and basically taking
jokic out of the game if they make
enough three-pointers they can take him
out of the game and not
have to really worry about his offensive
production if we're making
three-pointers we have the warriors have
to be making three-pointers but i think
that they can easily get past the
nuggets and you mentioned the memphis
grizzlies uh they're taking on the
timberwolves
those are two teams that are you know
they're they're not experienced the
warriors have that experience in the
playoffs i want to talk about the bench
the warriors bench is what's going to be
key for them in this one andre iguodala
and the boys they are going to have to
score they're going to have to score
they're going to have to play defense
they're going to have to be factors if
the warriors are going to win the west
and i'm not really too worried about
those phoenix suns sam i i just think
it's hard it's hard for me to believe
that chris paul can go in and beat a
steph curry led team uh this is hard for
me to see them beat the warriors four
times the phoenix songs and chris paul's
beat the words four times so i i
actually like this a lot i like this a
lot with my man drake
but before we get into uh before we get
to let's take a look at the current odds
let's take a look at the current odds
can we take a look at the current
outspeak because i just want to run
through it for you guys the phoenix sun
is -110 golden state wears plus 350
memphis there's oh plus 600 utah denver
and dallas rounds it out let me go to
the comments so i can see
so i can see what they are talking about
i see uh snoopy snoopy 2153 says sun
celtics will be a big time matchup
i like that uh
i know actually i do not like that i i
do not sun celtic it would be a big time
matchup but i do not see that happening
the golden state warriors is on the west
coast i mean it's on the western the
western division so uh i got gabriel
donnis warriors lock experience team
great team i agree with you
uh
one more sam i got one more in me
grizzlies will beat the wolves but it
will be a great series by bee heel four
shout out to everybody that i mentioned
you all are walking away with hoodies
all right sam we talked about the west
now let's talk about the east today we
asked you in the app who do you think is
coming out on top in the east and i need
everybody to get in the comments and
tell me who you are rocking with i'm
giving away an iphone
to my favorite comment but before i get
in the comments
let's take a look at the current odds
there they are you see milwaukee at the
top miami wow miami over brooklyn wow
wow miami you see boston up there you
see brooklyn philadelphia wow they're
plus 700
and in toronto rounding off the list sam
this one's interesting this one is very
interesting what are we thinking brother
yeah the east is absolutely fascinating
man that that side of the bracket is
going to be so fun i i really can't wait
if i had to give a pic it i it's a
boring answer but i think i would take
the bucks
and that is just because
the celtics uh the celtic nets have to
play each other in the first round and i
just that series is so two great teams
it's such a coin flip i would be nervous
betting one of those teams just because
they're they have such a tough first
round matchup whereas the bucks no
offense the bulls fans out there you
have literally no chance in that series
so uh i like the bucks to get to the
second round and then uh and then you'll
then they'll play the nuts or celtics
which will be amazing but um i like the
bucks i i think they can do it i think
they they're just an incredible team so
um
that that's where i would lean
sam's rocking with the bucks i see two
teams
that i'm you know considering
first i'll say
the team that i'm most considering
is the the next there's no question
we're talking about kevin durant kyrie
irving kevin durant is the best player
in the nba in my opinion right now kevin
durant is
and to beat them in a four game series
it's gonna be very very very tough
kevin durant almost did it he almost did
it last year against those bucks he's
coming back with the vengeance this year
sam
i can see him getting it done i can see
him getting it done now if i'm
sprinkling money trying to you know
throw a long shot out there
plus
776ers those philadelphia 76ers sitting
at plus
700 joel embiid james harden
i love the pick-and-roll offense it's
playoff basketball we only seen a
portion of it during the season sixers
fans do not be alarmed do not be alarmed
you guys will be okay
joel embiid
my man james harden but they will be
okay so if i'm putting if i'm throwing a
long shot i like the 76ers but if i'm
i'm putting my money right now sam and
i'm feeling good about it i'm putting my
money on the brooklyn nets and that's
what i'm rocking with but let me see
what the people
are talking about
i'm in the comments jesse24s he's
rocking with you sam he is rocking with
the bucks
okay okay jesse uh i also see bronco
jackson oh a brooklyn for the east they
are too stacked with katie and kyrie
like that take bronco jackson you two
are walking away with hoodies say i'm
the next one i see
i'm gonna give him the iphone
next one i see i'm gonna give him the
iphone all right here we go
three
bam
mar
maran517 says bucks run it back giannis
go get that 40 piece let's go easy chips
if not the nets going to steal it i like
that i mean
he mentioned the honest the the champs
then he said if not the nets are go
that's a great take that is a great take
that is deserving of an iphone shout out
to you you are walking away with an
iphone
sam
it's been real brother it has been real
thank you guys for tapping into the
group chat presented by fanduel remember
what you learned today the 3x2 was a lot
the br betting same game parlay is a lot
and me
we will be back next thursday me and sam
giving out more hoodies more jerseys and
more locks if you want a prize today we
will dm you i'm greg ivory alongside
the man
the myth the legend i need to see that
in the comments everybody type the man
the myth the legend sam richmond we are
leaving the group chat
peace
[Music]
you